AI has different uses and there's
different ways to interpret its results
and those also depend on human ability
to interpret things. So let's say if
you're using AI to do object detection,
you draw a square around the thing and a
human can't tell if a square is wrong,
right? If you're looking for a car and
the square is on a can, okay, like this
is wrong. You understand that?
um we go slightly a different way. Uh if
you're trying to do a bird
classification algorithm and the
algorithm tries to explain its reasoning
to you. So it says a robin. This bird is
a robin. Why? Because it has this kind
of a beak. It points out at a beak and
says beak and you kind of as a human
understand okay the beak is different
because different birds have different
beaks. Uh the color etc.
[Music]
John Sorowardi, thank you so much for
joining me today. I'm so excited to have
a conversation with you about the human
zero day. Um, really honored to have you
here. Thank you for joining all the way
from Rochester, New York.
>> Oh, yeah. Thank you for having me. Very
excited to talk about what we're going
to talk about.
>> Absolutely. So, so listen, John, you
know, we've been covering in this series
a bunch about social engineering, human
vulnerabilities, zero day attacks. One
of those zero day attacks is deep fakes.
>> And why do I say zero day attack? Well,
maybe you can explain it better than I
can because you're you're also looking
at from a cyber security space. So, so
why why are deep fakes effectively a
potential zero day attack?
Well, they're new. We're not prepared
for them. I mean, by we general public,
I would say, and ourselves as
researchers, there's lots of research
suggesting that I no matter how much we
do research, for a lot of times, we get
blindsided by deep fakes. And
>> honestly, these are not new. Um,
photoshopping's been around for years,
but deep fakes are not photoshopping.
They can the quality can vary a lot and
the amount the kinds of deep fakes I've
seen recently like oh
like we question what the real
information is these days cuz I'm like
oh is this compression or is this a deep
fake
so yeah
>> it it seems it's it reminds me a lot of
the way that malware came about in the
2000s and you have malware detection
which effectively looked for signatures,
right, in the in the malware. And now
the the types of signatures that one may
be able to find on deepixes has such
high variance that uh that it's not so
simple to to detect. How did you get
into the space of deep fakes?
>> Well, I got into space through my PhD.
So about when I started. So uh my
adviser was doing research in um network
traffic analysis earlier on actually and
he did some uh stuff in uh usability of
passwords authentication.
But my PhD started in 2018 and defakes
came about in end of 2017. So the timing
was great. There was a call for from
Night Foundation
um about helping journalists detect deep
fakes and my advisor suggested like I do
think we should go for this. I'm like
this is super interesting. it uses it
might use two things that I'm very good
at um understanding users and building
technology
and I really wanted to go dive deeper
into AI around that time and diving
aligned and we started working on it and
since 2018 I've been working uh deep
fake detection we've started worked with
journalists uh we worked with um
intelligence analysts which is a
different but very interesting group of
people. And we're also starting to work
with law enforcers right now and sort of
creating this ecosystem where we're
trying to sort of merge how people
understand deep fakes and we're
approaching it from a user side most
mostly while building technologies is
also important but there's lots of labs
who do that pretty well as well and
we're trying to plug the gap of hey
these are new technologies how would
they fit into your workflow how would
you do you understand what you're
reading or They're just happy cuz people
built tech and it looks fancy.
>> So I think this is an awesome awesome
point to to double down on this you this
question of user experience
in the context of truth seeking on
potential deep fakes.
>> Mhm.
>> Can you help me understand
from your perspective
what does that entail? You know, there's
many many worlds of AI models and
classifiers.
Most of them don't necessarily get the
attention of the need for user
experience like what you're saying here.
So why why deep fakes?
>> Um so AI has different uses and there's
different ways to interpret its results
and those also depend on human ability
to interpret things. So let's say if
you're using AI to do object detection,
you draw a square around the thing and a
human can't tell if a square is wrong,
right? If you're looking for a car and
the square is on a can, okay, like this
is wrong. You understand that? Um, we go
slightly different way. If you're trying
to do a bird classification algorithm
and the algorithm tries to explain its
reasoning to you. So it says a robin.
This bird is a robin. Why? Because it
has this kind of a beak. It points out
at a beak and says beak and you kind of
as a human understand, okay, the beak is
different because different birds have
different beaks. Uh the color, etc. Now
let's dive into things that humans don't
really understand. Well, and deep fakes.
So now you can traditional explanations
are heat maps generally or drawing
squares over things. Uh the first part
would be drawing a square around the
face and say making it red and saying
it's a deep fake like okay I understand
cuz deep fakes mean when face there's
something wrong with the face and
generally deep fakes do extract a face
and try to identify whether it's real or
not. So that doesn't really tell much to
the user. You might as well have a
number which most detectors have like
87% and that's what you get from a deep
fake detector generally.
>> So that doesn't really tell like why is
it a deep fake which is super important
for all three groups we work with. For a
journalist it's a deep fake. You can
write an article saying oh we ran
through a detector. It's 80%
uh deep fake. And we called some people
and they said, "Yeah, this is not real."
What people can lie to how what did the
model tell you that about this video
that it's a deep fake or the audio or
the picture now and now even text is
people use deep fake for text as well.
The terms very broad now. So the second
thing you do is heat maps as I
mentioned. Now, you could do um it seems
like a great idea to use heat mask for
deep fakes. Oh, this is a deep fake and
it focuses like there's lots of red on
the eyes. Okay. Uh user who's excited
about the tool. I say, "Oh, great. I I I
understand now the eyes." But then you
ask them like, "So, what about the eyes?
What do you think is wrong with it?"
Like, "I don't know. It's the eyes."
So, right. And that's where the question
is like and also
one people one thing people don't really
talk about but also do talk about is AI
can be wrong very confidently I am AI
this is 97% I'm 99% sure confident this
is a deep fake it's wrong it's a false
positive animals also give you a really
nice heat map like it's the eyes again
of course and there's research showing
that people even if people don't get
biased by a number and they do more
other kind of analysis. If you provide a
heat map, they might be more convinced
about a wrong result from AI. And here's
the problem with heat maps in this
space. Like I said, people we don't
really understand what the model's
talking about. The heat map is short for
deep learning researchers. It's great.
We understand that the model's focusing
on the ice to come up with the number
it's giving. But from interpretability
perspective, from regular users who need
to make decisions based on this, you
don't really understand what's
happening.
At that point, we need to sort of
understand what kind of information do
we give users
to make their decision. Yeah,
>> I I think you're touching on such an
amazingly interesting point. Um, and I
fully get your assessment as to why,
you know, numbers alone are not going to
cut it, obviously.
>> Mhm.
>> But then you're saying, well,
intuitively, many go for the heat map.
Not only does it look cool, it actually
kind of explains to you, you know, where
the fake is, but then you actually say,
well, not so much. It explains to you
where the where the AI focuses on and
what led to the derivation of the
number. Still doesn't explain why this
is a deep fake.
>> Mhm.
>> And and obviously there's the there's
the the what happens when when it's a
when it's claiming something with a
false positive or a false negative which
is which is obviously also detrimental.
>> Let's talk a little bit about
interpretability.
>> Mhm. So what what's what's there?
>> Um well there isn't too much in
interpret interpretability. Oh god the
word of def fakes these days. Um we're
trying to make progress. So
um we did some research on the existing
deep learning methods which is your grad
cans and everything. U but we're moving
more towards a statistical understanding
of images. what's at least trying to
get to what we can do right now and we
sort of got that idea from studying um
intelligence analysts
um in our studies which
works is in re under review so I won't
talk too much about it but um what they
suggested is like can you tell us what's
normal and what's abnormal about this so
you can use certain statistics to do
that. So through statistical
understanding you say regular general
images in this kind of category should
have these kind of statistics whether
you talk about color space whether
you're talking about compression you are
talk about um I guess movements if you
go into physics
so this is what a standard is and this
is what's wrong with the current content
you're looking at and there's research
labs who do biometric meth based methods
like um honey fared's lab and Berkeley
does a lot of that work
um where they've done papers which
analyze normal behaviors of people which
have strengths and their own weaknesses.
So as long as I guess an intelligent
person is using the tool and understands
the weaknesses and strengths of and each
method they could use various methods
that are available in research to sort
of build a case around a video. So
there's a lot of what traditional people
do really if a journalist tries to um do
a report and analyze information they
don't use just one tool and say oh this
is it we asked we talked to a person and
the person said this is false and hence
we publish it. No we build a case. Same
kind of approach should is what we're
asking to be used in the fake detection.
But also you have to be informed because
again a lot of vendors these days just
throw a lot of tools at people. Oh this
is what this is still is doing because
we told you so and here's four different
results from AI image detector but
there's very little to explain what are
the limitations strengths weaknesses
performance metrics of those things.
So, not maybe not many people need to
know that, but
from our experience, a lot of the people
we deal with do,
>> right? And it sounds like you're you're
dealing with a population and use cases
which are not only critical, but they
rely on the on the forensical approach
to to verifying information. and you're
dealing with the most fundamental part
of their job which is the actual
information
>> for verification right
and so it makes total sense why you need
this forensical approach and I can also
understand why in other cases as in with
perhaps enterprises or organizations
that are also concerned with deep fakes
why they may be okay with less
explanability
in many cases because perhaps they will
know event pretty quickly whether they
were right or wrong, right? Because this
would be used more in the context of
real-time communication, identity
verification, and if you get attacked by
a deep fake, well, you'll know in an
hour when you actually meet the person
in, you know, face to face and they'll
tell you.
>> Um,
how good are we today at detecting deep
fakes?
>> How good are we today at detecting deep
fakes? That's a good question. And well,
if you look at research space and data
sets, we're quite good at you'll always
see lots of papers with 99.98. We
ourselves published a paper where we did
100% accuracy on some subsets of data
sets, which is great, but I will
probably won't champion that work to be
used in open world. So, we still are
quite weak. So even there's research
showing um even though uh we're still
very bad on um out of I guess
distribution data and by that I mean if
you're trained on a certain type of deep
fakes or a group of certain type of deep
fakes that you know about and if you try
to test it on unknown deep fakes
on unknown techniques specifically it
does pretty bad your 100% or 98% sense
dive bomb into uh 65 68 70% confidence
levels accuracies and that's bad. But
beyond that, sure you could pat it with
multiple techniques and that does help a
lot like cuz the more you use but those
techniques have to be intelligently
applied intelligently applied. You have
to understand limitations of each tool
and sort of try to pat it as much as you
can like oh if one tool you're using is
weak against against certain things you
have to use another one that is strong
against those specific techniques.
That's one. But even then um we recently
did a workshop with law enforce law
enforcement
uh with a law enforcement group and we
did a hands-on study with we let them
use some unnamed defect detection models
I mean tools that are out there in the
world to be used by people and there
several people ran the same video
through and that tool let them select
different uh models They didn't really
understand much about the models because
there isn't much description of what
they do and if they want to learn more
they have to read a huge paper which few
people want to do.
Um and two different groups got two
different results for the same video
using two two different I guess
combinations of uh tools. And that kind
of tells you a lot about I guess the
space right now.
And I guess I'll leave it at that. We're
doing a lot of good progress and I would
say vendors are trying.
>> No, I think that I I mean know the
reason I'm curious is that
the and by the way, you know, we I the
I'm coming from the background of more
of a forensics approach. You know, we
got to work very intimately with CNN on
verifying media. It was incredible to me
to see the the intricate detailing that
you go into when you make such an
assessment
and you have simultaneously tools that
are it's important to have these
automated tools that can spit out a
result quickly because well I think that
ultimately we're going to have to embed
such tools across every part of our
digital interaction
whether it's in the detection part
whether it's in the authentication part
you know and I'm looking at the majority
of the space today and I'm seeing quite
a few making very bold claims 99%
accuracy
I'm getting even some of them claim that
they they'll give you insurance
>> yes
>> right if you so where is that confidence
coming from because I'm hearing you say
that Yeah, these are the right these are
the numbers in a constrained
indistribution environment, but in the
real world things are way different.
>> Um well, it's honestly it's no different
from the world of antiviruses and
malware.
Um and malware companies know that there
will be new attacks they can't um detect
or predict.
And there's also what they sort of I
guess how it's a little different from
malware cuz certain malware companies a
lot of them use handcrafted features cuz
there's lots more research and
understanding going into that field and
deep fakes
um early 2018 is when the detection
started. That is not many years,
especially given that we are in the age
of deep learning where we just throw
stuff at it and let it decide what it
wants to do where most groups are doing
that and it will mature and we will
reach a place where we can give
and actually give an insurance. I don't
really know how the companies give
insurance right now cuz I have thrown
videos at tools that I knew were real or
I knew were fake. Let's talk about the
example of um in America that Trump made
a speech after he was announced that he
won about
um attacking um targeting the deep state
though that was a long speech which a
lot of people started saying that it's a
deep fake. I have gotten people sending
me like, "Hey, is this real?" Like,
based on my understanding of deep fakes,
I'm looking at it seems very real. It's
like it's high quality. I don't see any
weird glitches. Uh the lots of giveaways
like the teeth look real. And if
somebody made this this quick, I feel
like it's real. I ran it through tools.
Some tools said it's fake. Some tools
said it real. And I'm like, "Oh god." If
somebody runs through this one and now
it goes through a Twitter and say, "Oh
my god, this is a deep fake like it
starts a whole thing." Thankfully, it
didn't or I didn't really see it that
much on social media.
But
tools are good. For most cases, they do
really well. But in those cases also I
can just look at the video and it's and
can really tell people because we work
um from our lab we collaborate with some
certain organizations where we sort of
provide them with our expertise. They
send us videos like, "Hey, can you take
a look at this and tell us what you
think?" And we sort of tell them like a
lot of the time it's most of these
videos are lip-sync videos and general
scams saying, "Oh, you'll get this much
money back." And people still sadly fall
for it, but and Nigerian princes still
probably get people to send them money
through spam. And so that that's not
surprising.
So and and and what so what types of you
know you mentioned before in
distribution out of distribution what
types of deep fakes today or what types
of media today is the industry
getting really good at detecting is
there can you can we classify a use case
where this is becoming you know a a a a
place where real value can be derived
with with a low false positive false
positive rate. Um, I would say the lip
sync cases,
um, at least the generic lip sync videos
are very one, they're v they're
relatively easy to identify manually,
but
uh, the models are also very good at
that. There's very low I guess false
positive ratio for that for a model
that's trained well. I wouldn't say all
of them
but carefully wellbuilt model
well-trained model is quite good at
doing that. face swaps certain in
certain cases it's good but there's so
many like for each category there's so
many techniques these days it's very
hard to say like that we're getting good
at this category
like for lip sync there's wave to lip
there's a method you would know uh
that's super popular mostly because
there's lots of like there's hugging
phase there's GitHub repository that
gets you started up really fast even cuz
the for face swaps you need to learn up
certain things to do good work for wave
to lip you you just give it an audio you
give it a video and you're done
a lot of time it does good a lot of
times it does terribly but scammers
don't really care cuz the whole point of
it is just quick and dirty attack and
you distribute it if you get five people
giving you money it's a
So
>> sure,
>> it's really hard to say what we're
getting good at. And trendwise, I
haven't seen that we're super good at
this one type. Maybe a a company is
better suited to tell you that because
they have they constantly collect the
data.
>> For us in research, I haven't seen us
>> be good at any of the categories, I
would say.
And from your perspective, you know, a
lot of people are talking about the fact
that this is an arms race, right? This
is like in the antivirus game. It's it's
an arms race. And in an arms race, you
have the two sides moving fast.
Generally, one side is moving faster.
Rarely, it's in equilibrium.
What's moving faster here? the
generation of new improved diverse deep
fakes or the resiliency and robustness
of detecting deep fakes.
Um I would like to say that from
research perspective
the research of detection is moving
faster at least there's more keeps
coming out and addressing this or
understanding people's perception of
these fakes or understanding the
weaknesses
and I guess the generation is there's a
little less papers and generation coming
out
but
We're still stuck behind
an understanding how people outside of
the research space, the malicious
adversaries, what kind of things would
they be using to avoid us is what I
guess the research is still struggling
with. And again, that's also because
there aren't that many adversaries in
deep fake detection. There aren't any
groups that use deep fakes to attack
nation states or something. There's been
pretty like out there videos in the
Russia Ukraine war of Putin and uh
Zillinski announcing things but that was
also debunked within a day. Yes. I mean,
even if it was debunked within a day,
there could have been lots of effects of
that of people dying in
because they looked at the video and
listened to it. But there are no unlike
malware where the known groups and
there's lots of malware constantly being
built and you can sort of build an
understanding of what the adversarial
community uses
um what kind of things they use. For
defects, we don't really have that yet.
We have what researchers
use and we ourselves try to attack
ourselves of sorts and this is great
like the from the security and the blue
teaming red teaming thing works really
well but I guess for if you look at it
from that perspective I feel like
um the generation's moving faster by not
moving that much
because we have the we don't really know
what to expect right now
and for two elections in a row we
thought defakes are going to play a huge
part in the elections and they really
didn't like there were lots of
expectations fine there were lots of
images generated
of um the
candidates and weird things and there
was a popular video not very popular
video of Biden talking about a magical
pistachio. I don't know if you've seen
the video,
>> of course,
>> but yes, but beyond that, there isn't
there wasn't really much that you could
say, oh, this is a headline. Oh my god,
this has happened.
>> Yeah.
>> And we try to and and when do you think
we'll get there? If you think we'll get
there. If I think we'll I mean
it's hard to say like disinformation is
such a complex
field and def fakes fall in under that.
So it's like asking a question. Do you
know if you're a part of a
disinformation campaign
and or
have do you think your narrative has
been artificially changed by a national
state nation state and it's a hard
question to answer like I don't know
so similarly maybe there are certain
deep fakes that we aren't aware of that
were crafted super well then built into
a really good narrative and we don't
know about that yet. But from general
disinformation perspective,
I don't really see
much that's super super concerning. But
that doesn't say we should stop working.
We need to make sure that doesn't
happen. Maybe we are doing a good enough
job that it doesn't reach that point.
Hasn't reached that point yet.
>> Exactly.
Well, John, I think that uh obviously
you've you've been around the block in
the context of deep fakes and I love the
thoughtfulness that you give to
and the respect you're giving to this
space and uh very curious how it will
continue emerging. I'm curious how the
arms race will continue curious about
how user experience will come about
within different within different types
of groups. And we didn't even get to go
into the how from a user experience
perspective. It it it can work with
within the context of journalism and the
context of law enforcement and and I
think that that merits a whole separate
conversation because this is it's a
fascinating field and I really want to
thank you for your time and for being
here. So thank you so much. Really
appreciate you.
>> Thank you for having me and good luck
with uh clarity as well. Hope you guys
>> prevent a lot of deep fakes.